pas
[Musique]
hilale pays était à l'honneur ce
week-end à petite-ile
en effet pendant trois jours la ville a
mis en place de nombreuses animations
telles que le grand défilé d'halloween
ou encore le concours de la plus belle
bosse die une fête importante pour le
maire de petite île qui souhaitent
valoriser les producteurs nos
agriculteurs ont besoin que nous soyons
à leurs côtés notamment lorsqu'il s'agit
de productions agricoles qui subissent
l'importation et la décision qu'on a
prise au département de mettre en place
un dispositif de soutien aux produits
identitaires prend tout son sens l'année
dernière j'avais huit planteurs die sur
cette fête cette année j'aurai 14
lenteur qui grâce au soutien du
département ont pu relancer la culture
d'aia petit team et nous espérons écoulé
entre 15 et 20 tonnes cette année
ce travail porte ses fruits et le fruit
à petit il sait live en événements lance
en 2014 qui attire beaucoup de monde qui
permet aux producteurs d'écouler leurs
récoltes
ça leur permet
jusqu'à maintenant ça permet tait de
vente pratiquement la production de
partir
pendant tout un week-end donc elle
s'arrête et ça aussi et à promouvoir la
paix et comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure
dans mon discours
on s'aperçoit aussi que il ya eu une
chute et un but de planteurs et
aujourd'hui on commence à avoir plus une
augmentation des gens qui replantent la
rue malgré des conditions
météorologiques défavorables cette année
la récolte a été bonne et la qualité
était au rendez vous la présente plus
les gens étudiants de plus en nombreux
pour
serge un spot savoir le lay
la halle fait beaucoup de faux bond ou
sans grande et l'ail pays et 3 kg de
l'ail de chine et moi même la différence
c'est le coup c'est une fort dans le
pari
[Musique]